in disney's moana we see former wrestler
dwayne the rock johnson play maui a
powerful polynesian demigod
that makes sense but who knew he could
sing well
old school wrestling fans that's who
bright light city gonna set my soul
gonna set my soul on fire
viva rock vegas indeed from that to
highest earning actor in the world oh
man you have come a long way dwayne
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
where
rock mr rock dwayne can i call you
dwayne if you're watching dwayne no need
to thank me for dredging up all those
old embarrassing clips what else can i
say except for
you're welcome segway 2 moana the new
disney classic that needs no
introduction there's a lot to love with
moana from the gorgeous visuals to songs
written by the guy who made musicals
cool again lin-manuel miranda to a
chicken
obviously named after the guy reminding
us that this is library
hey hey this is library or
just me impersonating a valley girl hey
hey while lilo and stitch give us a
small glimpse of hawaiian culture
moana really feels like it's celebrating
the legends and traditions of
all of polynesia stories that have been
almost completely absent in pop culture
history
now if you're a regular watcher of this
series you might be thinking to yourself
yeah yeah matpat talk all you want about
how nice this movie is i just know that
you're gonna tell me that moana is the
devil
or that maui is a serial killer or that
the pig is actually moana's brother and
you know what
i can't blame you for that dear theorist
in the recent past my theories on
light-hearted animated movies have
tended to stray a bit to the dark
side but you've judged me too quickly
because for today's moana theory i
turned over a new leaf i tried something
different and i
focused on something positive and after
looking at all the fantastical elements
of moana as well as some polynesian
mythology my theory
ended up being moana is dead
oh i'm like the living embodiment of
dark kermit but
seriously there are some weird
happenings going on in moana's little
boating adventure that need an
explanation the first and biggest red
flag that set off my theorist sense was
that she's able to follow maui into
lalota
the realm of monsters i mean at the very
least this extended fall into the water
should kill her the surface tension of
water makes landing on it from a very
high place like landing on concrete and
the movie even makes multiple jokes
about how long the fall is and the fact
that she should be dead
after it well she's dead sure all this
is fine for maui because he's a demigod
but it just seemed like something that a
human shouldn't be able to do
so i looked it up and learned that in
early drafts of the movie lalotai was
described as a place for ancestral
spirits i.e the dead
and that the directors of the movie john
musker and ron clements still refer to
it as the underworld in the special
features of the film
first entered the underworld so my fears
about the scene weren't getting any
better but i
swear to you internet i was determined
to stay positive
maybe in polynesian myth humans can go
to the underworld so i dug
even deeper and learned that the
polynesian underworld is usually called
polotu rather than lalotai
and according to william mariner an
english writer who lived in tonga in the
early 19th century polotu was said to be
both invisible and
inaccessible to mortals we even get a
hint of that in the movie when tamatoa
the giant coconut crab expresses
confusion about moana's presence in
lalota
asking her what are you doing down here
in the realm
of the month just pick an eye baby so
that was red flag number one add to it
the fact that moana frequently sees the
spirit of her dead grandmother tala and
you've got yourself no
ordinary day for a mere mortal there's
even a scene in the movie that could
definitely have killed her the first
time moana tries to sail beyond the reef
her boat gets overturned by a large wave
she's then tossed into the water the
canoe bonks her on the head and her foot
gets stuck under a piece of coral i mean
i'm no doctor but getting smacked in the
head by a large piece of wood then
getting trapped under water for an
extended period of time seems pretty bad
for your health and from that point
forward moana seems like she's
impervious to harm look i'm not even
having to dig into genetics or weird
scientific connections this one is
outright handed to me
kind of you see on the surface the idea
of moana being dead is interesting and
would make for a great
click bait thumbnail but if we look
again the evidence doesn't hold up for
instance if that reef crash is indeed
the moment where she passes on then the
people in her village are interacting
with a ghost for an awfully long amount
of time like it's no big deal
and interacting is one thing but making
a teenage ghost girl your next chief
that is where i draw the line also it's
worth noting that the whole thing about
her talking to her grandmother's spirit
is
rooted in polynesian legend according to
anthropologist zachary graves in
traditional polynesian culture
ghosts are often thought to interact
with a living whether for good or for
evil and if they're both dead why's
grandma a glowing white spirit thingy
and moana is just
moana the theory just falls apart and
yet there's something
fishy still going on because let's face
it none of this explains my initial
concern
why moana can go to lalotai survive that
fall into the underworld
land of ancestors realm of monsters
moana may not be
dead but she is something so i kept
digging
determined to figure out what exactly
was going on and i found out that my
original theory of her being dead
couldn't have been more wrong in fact
when i step back to look at all the
evidence
she's the exact opposite of being dead
moana
is a god well
demigod actually she's just like maui
let me explain
first moana's relationship with water is
a bit weird right
after decades of the heart of te fiti
being missing the ocean just
chooses moana what because she saved a
baby turtle
i don't think so who wouldn't save a
cute baby sea turtle it just seems
weird why her and why now what makes
moana so special
more on that in a minute also the
ocean's treatment of her is pretty
inconsistent she almost drowns in her
first boating adventure but after that
moment she's virtually invulnerable to
the sea
every time maui throws her off the boat
she gets thrown right back on when she
asks the sea to help her find maui
yes she gets caught in a storm but it's
a storm that washes her up on the shore
of maui's
island and every time the heart of te
fiti goes into the drink the ocean spits
it right back at her like a big
petrified loogie
yeah we're making phlegm jokes when i
wrote it i thought it was funny but now
looking back
it's not it's not at all anyhow all of
these demonstrate how moana and the
crbffs but the one moment that's really
striking is at the very end of the movie
when spoiler alert moana orders the
ocean to move fish
get out the way so that she can confront
takeha and the water parts right in
front of her to clear a path on the
ocean floor
now obviously this is very reminiscent
of the iconic scene in the bible where
moses parts the red sea with the divine
power of god on the side and if this was
what the movie was
referencing it would hurt my case for
moana being a demigod since moses is
immortal but remember
we're talking about polynesian beliefs
drawing a parallel to a bible verse here
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
what would really help me out though is
if there were some sort
of similar story from polynesian
mythology and wouldn't you know it
i've got one one hawaiian legend tells
of kane abua who's described as a god
with a human form who was able to cause
water to flow from rocks and make a safe
passage across the sea
now maui certainly doesn't have that
kind of power if he did he could have
escaped from his island long before his
thousand-year exile was up so it seems
likely that the one calling the shots
here
is moana herself the second thing that
points to moana being more than human
is simply her name the name moana means
ocean
or deep sea in a few of the pacific
languages from maori to hawaiian
and while the sea could have chosen
moana because it's like hey girl we got
the same name so i'm gonna send you on a
quest
it's much more likely that disney's
continuing the polynesian pattern of
having deities whose names
are the things that they're gods of for
example te fiti is the maori god of wind
and storms
translated the name tafiri means wind
paley is a polynesian god of fire whose
name means volcano
and rang is a god of the sky whose name
means say it with me now
skittles sorry i was just making sure
you're paying attention of course
it means sky now maybe the writers of
moana simply aren't very creative and
arbitrarily chosen name that means water
but does that sound like disney or is it
more likely that the creators of this
movie
who literally formed a full oceanic
trust of advisors to make sure they
honored the culture their movie was
portraying
chose the kind of name that would be
given to a demigod of the sea
still all this leaves us with one
problem demigods don't just come out of
nowhere either they're born to divine
parents or else they're somehow created
like maui when his parents tossed him
into the sea
and he presumably died so maybe that
means moana no
stop it turned away from that road and i
am not looking back
part three of the evidence that moana
isn't mortal and prepare to have your
mind blown
is about her lineage now both of moana's
parents tui and cena appear to be
mortals but that's not quite the end of
the story
for starters grandmother tala with whom
moana has a particularly close
relationship might not be mortal herself
tala is the name of the goddess of the
stars in tagalog
myth and oh would you look at that she
just so happens to use the stars to
demonstrate to moana how she can find
maui now obviously that's incidental but
get ready because here's the doozy
moana's mother's name is cena
completely unrelated cena happens to be
the name of a famous maiden from
polynesian mythology
this maiden was loved by an eel but cena
the maiden was like ew gross eel love
and reported the problem to her husband
who then killed the eel
and buried its carcass from that dead
eel sprang the coconut tree
and thus coconuts came into the world
does that sound like a familiar story
it should because it's a story that maui
sings about in the song
you're welcome i killed your meal i
buried its guts sprouted a tree
oh yeah did i mention that cena's
husband in that legend is named
maui and not just some dude named maui
but the trickster demigod
tui you are not the father
remember that moana's quote-unquote
father the chief is the one who forbids
her to sail beyond the wreath but when
her mother discovers that she's going to
sail off secretly into the night she
says
nothing she actually helps moana pack
her things and sends her on her way
it always felt like such a weird moment
to me but it makes a whole lot more
sense when her mother sees this
dangerous voyage as inevitable moana as
a demigod being compelled to go out and
accomplish greater things
and along the way find her real father a
father whose immortal blood is the key
to her own powers
over the ocean that's right moana is the
daughter
of maui now i admit nowhere was i able
to find that moana is the name of the
child of maui and cena so getting 100
confirmed status on this
is impossible unless one of the creators
of the movie steps forward and says yay
but i was able to find one last mind
blow for you that rockets this thing
into the stratosphere
one of the children cena and maui did
have was named kamapua and this wasn't
just any ordinary kid according to the
lore it actually
looked like a pig huh ever wonder why
the people of montanui didn't eat
moana's pet pig if they had no fish and
failing crops well
that pig's name is pua which sounds an
awful lot like it's short for kamapu
ah that's right the pig and moana is
indeed
moana's brother talk about your weird
family tree so there you have it no
serial killers
no devils but a pig that's related to
our latest disney princess
and a hidden godlike lineage that moana
will never know about
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and
cut ring the subscription bell my
friends not only do i cover
disney theories like literally all the
time but also i think i deserve it after
this one
polynesian mythology isn't the easiest
thing to research but we managed to do
it and come up with a really cool theory
that honestly i think is a hundred
percent true so ring that bell
and hey if you're in the mood for
another disney theory click right here
and last but not least that box on the
right side of the screen is supposed to
be
best for your viewing experience let me
know what shows up there i'm trying to
figure out what youtube is actually
serving up to you guys trying to figure
out what these weird mechanisms that
youtube is rolling out what they do and
how they work so tell me what's in that
box and hey
if you like it click on it go watch that
episode i hope it's a good one
i hope they're right that it is the best
one for you now anyway if you'll excuse
me i gotta go and
actually going to travel for a couple
weeks but there's still new theories
coming up on stuff that is a little bit
more mature
uh we're getting some more mature stuff
in the next couple weeks so
that'll be fun enjoy moana